[Music]
[Applause]
all right where are we going we're going
to the expendables recycler the legend
is that this guy just started getting
deals on surplus expendables which are
half tape c47s like gels anything that's
expendable now he sells them out of his
garage so we'll see if the prices are
still
garage prices
[Music]
spencer
what have you done here
we've recreated our street in vr
it's so hard looking at stuff in vr like
this close to your face oh wow look at
this
if only i could jump this high in real
life this is like really high detail
whoa
this is pretty good did a pretty good
job with this for being a single pass
with an automated process
yeah
all right slamming down the street
[Music]
so we found it
yeah man literally just the house this
is the house
how's it going hey guys been here before
uh once or twice
[Music]
we got viewfinder cushions really cool
and really helpful
holy cow
our surplus price is 11.85 so these are
either going to be that or marked down
from that although okay
yeah it's fine so apparently they label
their tape with
0.9.8 etcetera to basically tell how
full it is if it's you about ninety
percent full yeah ten percent's been
used by someone else so you get a bit of
a discount
we do need more c47 c47 is our clothes
pins the reason why they call it c47s is
a long time ago gaffers and dps needed
them to put gels on their lights but
studios didn't want to pay for them so
they called them something super fancy
which convinced all the accountants that
it was really important i heard a
different story what i heard was that
that was just their number in a catalog
of like grip equipment i heard the story
of a man's wife had it listed as c47 on
the inventory but he couldn't put
clothespins and charge the amount he was
charging hadn't heard that one before
i heard it was in bin 47 in row c at the
universal stock room that was going way
way way back
we got a black gap yeah white gaff
basically three rolls of tape a bunch of
c47s for 30 bucks a great success does
sound a lot and you're right it is kind
of a lot of money but to get it brand
new at a normal store double easily
long story short we're going to do a
previz at our friend joel's place what
do you do in a previz basically you got
your shot list which nico and i made
we're going to go through and roughly
frame things block it first there's a
stage called blocking where you figure
out everybody's position since this is a
fight scene blocking is extra important
you're not just standing there talking
to somebody you're moving all over the
place we went through and figured all
that blocking out we figured out our
stunts we figured out our angles and
generally our coverage am i confident
about the shoot
come on
the mobility of the cardboard costumes
is the only x factor at the moment the
only challenge on the shoes the costumes
are probably gonna fall apart as we
shoot but that's okay we'll fix them we
got lots of tape i learned how many more
minecraft costumes i should have built
realistically i think we have enough
we're just gonna need to be tactical
about how we smash them up i'm gonna
panic about it well when i start to
panic usually i neurotically
move like this back and forth every like
30 seconds i make a yelping noise as i
gasp for air like